c'est officiel jean pascal lacoste fait
sa grande arrivée dans la famille des
pmp un chanteur animateur comédien qui
devient pour la toute première fois
chroniqueur médias
c'est en 2001 que jean pascal apparaît
sur les écrans de télé à l'occasion de
la toute première saison de la star ac
sur tf1 sans trop savoir pourquoi le
jeune homme se retrouve au casting de ce
concours de chant si visiblement sa voix
d'ange n'a pas toujours convaincu tous
les enfants de ma cité sa bonne humeur
et son histoire d'amour avec jennifer
feront décoller les audiences du
programme et le feront connaître de la
france entière une notoriété qu'il
mettra une fois encore au profit de la
grande chanson française
je suis
[Musique]
durant 7 ans et dans section de
recherches la série policière de tf1 que
jean pascal fera ses armes en tant que
comédien passons ici du rôle d'agitateur
à celui de policier
c'était aussi un ami monsieur le
procureur en 2008 il sera même animateur
télé sur nrj 12 à la tête de l'émission
les 12 coeurs mais aussi de ça passe ou
ça trappe
c'est donc un artiste aux multiples
facettes que nous accueillons autour de
la table un chroniqueur qui on l'espère
regardera la même audace vestimentaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors donc wasquehal enfin ça le regarde
et qu'on va voir page toujours pas ce
candidat est ce qu'on peut faire un plan
sur jean pascal et ce qui est toujours
un réalisateur ou quelqu'un d'aussi haut
s'il te plaît mon chéri parce que si tu
te mets dans leur tour forcément je vais
pas le voir un 25 ans de télé merci
alors est-ce qu'on peut le voir je pense
qu albert si mes chéris ils voient bien
voilà il est frais j'aime bien si c'est
bien ça fait plaisir
franchement j'aime beaucoup je suis très
content qu'il soit là mais vous pouvez
dire que c'est une mauvaise idée je me
rappelle à l'époque on a dit plein de
fois qu'ils avaient des chroniqueurs
c'était une mauvaise idée
alors bonne idée ou mauvaise idée
l'arrivée de jean pascal dans touche pas
à 20 dans touche pas à mon poste l'année
prochaine et pour l'instant donc c'est
que du qui je vais donner la parole car
je suis extrêmement galon mais un
entendu je vais donner la parole
convient et ma série à jean mi mauvaise
idée
pourquoi aurait il est pourtant l'île du
sud ouest et de ses je kiffe le sud
ouest
mais déjà il a une réputation qui le
précède et imputation de branleurs et je
pèse mes mots
voilà et je trouve que dans cette
émission la cuisine soignée on a une
réputation va c'est pas le var et par
l'autre ils travaillent pas beaucoup et
ça ça me gêne terrible à vous vous
trompez y travaille peut-être
certainement plus que vous c'est parce
qu'on m'a dit j'espère que l'effet de
prouveront le contraire mais voilà je
trouve que voilà ici ça rigole beaucoup
mais avant on ne voit pas beaucoup mis
énormément de travail et ça faut le
savoir aussi de se passer de mauvaises
idées ces mauvaises idées aussi parce
que déjà c'est un beau gosse ça j'avoue
il est beau gosse mais deux beaux gosses
dans l'émission je parle de vous
évidemment n'ose parler de vous je pense
sinon moi je parle de vaches rousses et
il repart de louga ma de loup alpha dans
la meute voilà vous êtes dominant
jean-pascal j'ai peur qu'il soit passé à
les modèles il est très sympa mais
messieurs on a déjà parlé avant
l'émission avait faire du golf et
biarritz et voilà et puis deux
sérieusement
il s'appelle lacoste et jpeg papa de ma
folle quand même s'il a causé un
crocodile et crocodile c'est connu voire
une grande gueule des petites couilles
donc
bah oui mais moi je peux plus vous
voulez je peux plus alors allez-y elle
est là veulent à leur lama depuis tout à
l'heure elle ça fait deux heures qui
lève la main même de même pour rien dire
oui à l'isi pour rien dire résidant
alors professionnellement parlant moi je
pense que on lui a toujours proposé des
rôles qui n'ont pas abouti parce que je
pense qu'on n'a pas su le cerner et vous
vous êtes le premier à bien cerner les
gens et à savoir ce qu'on peut faire ou
non avec ses ça fait dix ans que les
patients mais je pense que jean pascal
il est parfait pour cette émission et je
pense que ça va justement aboutir parce
que vous avez vu qu'il avait vu qu'ils
avaient laden d'art cas là il a déjà
commencé achèveront toutes les nanas
dans les couloirs il ya sa femme qui
regarde donc c'est obligé là pas du tout
au plus il se dit j'ai discuté avec lui
des frères fidel et très amoureux mais
oui mais non mais laisse rien amour mais
quand je dis s'ébranler daniel sanchez
en elle pour dépenser d'électricité à
venir y avait quelques mois par mois il
y avait là y'avait delfina styliste
chercher deux lieux du courant et la fée
tchad harel a pris le veut la mettre là
voilà c'est tout à la rigolade non je
parle pas là des choses voilà bien sûr
des leurs et voilà donc la bonne humeur
exact réunis dans le passé les
compétences qu'il a acquis seront bonnes
pour cette émission
bah moi moi je moi je moi je veux la
d'or depuis des années je vous dis et je
l'aimais énormément humainement déjà y
est vous savez à chaque fois que je vois
quelqu'un dans l'émission c'est qu'avant
tout je laime je les aime parce que ça
c'est une belle personne non mais c'est
vrai c'est un mec sympathique cinq mois
je suis très content voilà de quoi qu'il
arrive et je pense qu'il va réussir
voilà on va demander à bah oui j'adore
moi c'est je pense que c'est la
meilleure idée que vous avez eu depuis
longtemps j'adore j'adore jean pascal
mais vraiment je l'avais appelé un jour
pour le dire à quel point je trouvais
qu'ils progressaient bien quel point je
trouvais qu'ils jouaient bien et en plus
il a une vraie forte personnalité ans le
musée le pas comme on veut et alors avec
vous et je pense qu'il ya des moments
qui voit une vraiment drôle tankink pour
ça alors vous voyez déjà mâché les
derniers oui mais c'est un garçon qui me
fait beaucoup rire en plus ça va super
aller maxime rabot je suis très content
comme beaucoup téléspectateurs j'ai
découvert la star academy en 2001
j'avais 14 ans et j'étais le premier à
avoir acheté le jingle l'agitateur c'est
vraiment le premier prendra un des
premiers
fun et j'étais fan du personnage est un
agitateur avec un peu plus de maturité
je crois qu'il a vraiment sa place dans
tpm p mine de rien il y aura marqué la
télévision des années 2000 et puis il a
passé le mot sa poche j'ai vu un live un
stade où il disait des choses et bah oui
la passe à lens allait passer la mousse
à poste et c'est un bon gars un gars
bienveillant donc bienvenue au club
bienvenue au club merci à les voilà
salut bienvenue chez les ringards c'est
vraiment une bonne idée parce que je
pense que c'est alors viens vous avant
d'alors jean pascal donc tourné vous
cette élégance cette famille c'est père
en fils et le père en fils condamné
comme ça ou ça vous de trouver sur la
toile la violence tout dépend de savoir
parce que quand je vois quelqu'un
d'élégant partout cible à le tee shirt
je dis stop
non mais vraiment sans rigoler vous ai
lu ce genre n'était il prend juste un
petit chalet sport et les trois pêcheurs
des trois maillots
il habille et pour tout l'été a pas
besoin de plus et c'est la mémoire mais
quelle élégance qui va du salami vous
avez des origines quoi ces zones de
quelle origine
moi je suis français d'origine marocaine
bah voilà alors bien sûr aller
franchement rassuré sur la glace les
marocains les algériens des tunisiens
ils ont la classe et lui lui où il fera
beau vraiment je vous dis c'est pas je
vous dis et ligue en rien la vie sauf
qu'il achète pas ses affaires à rabat
mais au rabais oignons maroc
bîmes kalach sur tille sortira au lieu
sortie de bonnes pour tous dégagé dégagé
ce qu'il faut expliquer aux gens c'est
que pour réduire le nombre de gens n'y a
pas de cynisme n'y a pas de maquillage
ya pas de coiffure donc on vient avec
son bouillon il faudra juste d
voilà juste des bottes dégager le camion
alors et donc oui sur jean pascal super
idée parce que je pense qu'à un vrai
gentil pour avoir parlé avec lui un
texto il
ils pensent bien et réagit bien et
j'aime bien les parcours de vie moi
j'aime bien quand ils adorent ça
il fait un truc et qu'on lui dis pas tu
fera sa toute ta vie il a fait un truc
qui l'a fait astarac après les partis
faire un autre truc un autre chose
il avait un restaurant et a fermé son
restaurant et repart sur autre chose
j'adore ces gens là et en plus il est
franc et il dit les choses et j'espère
qu'il sera pas muselée et s'il est pas
museler pour l'année prochaine lui rené
malleville ça va être extraordinaire
c'est en ce moment tu vas être dans une
courbe tu veux être dans une classe de
cp1 il va falloir tenir tout le monde ça
va être dur à tenir je le dis parce que
les mecs vont dire la vérité et j'espère
que jean pascal dira la vérité
qu'est-ce que vous avez bon secours moi
je suis bien en suisse via le soleil je
suis je mets des t-shirts je viens assez
que duke est bon je vois des gens c'est
sur ces les masques sa maman ça me fait
chier ça m'embête part de sa vie envie
de parler ça mais j'ai beaucoup envie de
parler je crois je veux m'inscrire à
tellement vrai c'est vrai c'est vraiment
vrai qu'ils ont un dos lâche je pense
qu'il a un truc moi ce que vous suivre
et à faire une nouvelle version
tellement élégant
non mais vraiment c'est vrai vous y
croyez pas moi j'en passe quatre qui
vont chercher c'est vous qui a été
chercher
battus 3-2 mais aux yeux qui vous a dit
prends jean pascal thurre a sèchement
bien c'est pas un pantin
mais c'est pas une question de porter
des fois on te conseille des gens
étudiants oui c'est une bonne idée je
vais le prendre parce que je les aime
bien c'est pas une question de pantin
mais mais moi je vous le dit felice mal
si je vous connais très bien je sais
très bien que c'est vous qui décidez
n'ont pas dû à votre box décimés ces
duels stan le directeur qui a abattu un
cépage est pas toujours mais mais mais
pour moi ça va j'ai eu lieu à nice
cannes alors je vais vous dire pourquoi
le directeur de zoo je vais vous
raconter
c'était le producteur de jean-pascal sur
12 coeurs c'était lui le producteur de
tous coeur sur nrj 12 avec mehdi
harbaoui voilà un pote également donc
voilà donc je vous le dis et donc et il
était très très pour prendre jean pascal
boyer ou pas il est vrai qu'il n'est pas
si c'est vraiment voyez une fois de plus
ils dévoilent des bêtises et c'est vrai
que lionel stan voulait absolument que
jean pascal aussi nous rejoignent et
voilà comme celle de directeur général
le dg on ferme de gueule et on dit
d'accord voilà merci c'est je crois
qu'il est en régie voilà je crois qu'il
a deux trois qui veulent des
augmentations bien entendu vous
l'appellerait demain ils vous raccroche
raonnais
cherry et bien jean pascal on va voir un
question penses toi
valérie c'est important l'avis du public
et l'avis des téléspectateurs
ouais je pense que en tant que
représentante du public aujourd'hui je
pense que jean pascal il est vraiment
très sympathique et très spontanée très
authentique et il change pas que thomas
a besoin de cela je suis énormément il
reste authentique ils changent pas de
tactique jean pascal c'est aussi pour ça
que je la donne alors les chiroux avoir
tout de suite au sondage pour ou contre
bonne idée à 62% hui la mauvaise idée à
38% je vous dis c'est pas mal du tout
parce que généralement et je connais
vous êtes assez sévère avec des
nouvelles recrues et là qui est 62 % des
gens qui disent que c'est une bonne idée
c'est plutôt du positif